hey Jenna how are you I'm good how are
you I'm good I want to show you a visual
of me dressed as Wednesday Adams just to
show you how excited I am for this
series can you see it it's so good yes I
can thank you for that amazing I love
you in this role Wednesday's such an
iconic character do you have nerves when
you're taking on a character like this
or just pure excitement yeah I think I
think that's bound to happen I think oh
well I'm someone who just naturally gets
very nervous about my work I feel like
every day I show up on a set I feel like
I'm gonna throw up
um which I mean it's kind of nice
because it keeps me on my toes but yeah
I think I think with someone who has has
such a legacy and is such an icon and
someone that you know is very very loved
there's always pressure with something
like that but then there's also just
pressure that I put on myself to do a
good job and do her justice you know
what do you love about this version of
Wednesday
I love that we just kind of see a bit
more to her there's a bit more Dimension
there because you know in previous
iterations she's always the one-liner or
you know the side character so I think
that you get to know her a little bit
better and also it's a different world
it's a different setting I I kind of had
freedom in that sense where I could kind
of stray from what we know about 90s
Wednesday per se and I think that that
was a really interesting thing to um
Carry and try when you know trying to
lead a story in an emotional Arc
well speaking of 90s Wednesday you and
Christina have such great scenes
together what's it like having her
support on set
really wonderful she's such I mean she's
she's been in this industry for such a
long time she's such a professional
she's so good at what she does she's
definitely
um a very generous actor and and plays
into your needs and and you want to play
into hers and it's really wonderful to
to have that rapport with someone who
yeah not only is so familiar with this
character but also is just talented
did she give you any piece of advice
when it comes to playing Wednesday no we
didn't talk about Wednesday at all
that's actually probably really good I
know it was weird we didn't it was just
like we just both knew not to mention
her name and it was nice I think that
she knew that it probably wouldn't
benefit me in any way and and vice versa
I love that okay so Wednesday spends
this series really trying to solve this
mystery if you had to solve a murder
mystery with one member of the cast in
real life who'd you pick
um
there's a part of me that just always
wants to be with Emma Myers all the time
uh so I love you two together in this
show she's also so smart she's so smart
she's a perfect human it's really yeah
actually I'm not even going to give you
a second option it's just Emma
okay so Emma and a couple of the other
cast members said that you are so
similar to Wednesday do you agree with
that
to an extent I think I actually remember
I think Percy told me one time on set I
think I said something off camera and he
said I think you're more Wednesday than
Wednesday and with that I take great
appreciation and thanks right because he
loves Wednesday because he was saying
she just says what we're all thinking
with no no shame she just says it yeah
she's yeah she's a cool cool cat
I love that you know a lot of people
have been calling you this generation
scream Queen which as a big fan of
horror films I agree what do you think
of that title and who are some of your
favorite scream Queens thank you I feel
I I feel like I can't really say it
myself and I've never really
that wasn't like the goal or or whatever
so I mean I appreciate it because I
think it's very very sweet I feel like I
still have much work to do before I
could take such a such a such a such a
cool title but it's
it's wonderful Horrors one of my
favorite genres ever I think I always
have some of the best moments on set
when I'm doing horror and and it's a lot
of fun and I love being covered in blood
and I love screaming bloody murder and
it's just it's it's a lot of fun for me
I love that love being covered in blood
um speaking of just icons of this genre
Tim Burton I mean is this real life what
was that like for you
kind of even now I kind of think about
it and it's it's so strange to me
because he is such a normal person it's
like he doesn't even know that his name
is Tim and you know obviously he has his
own little quirks and and ways about him
and you know it was always so
interesting on set when he would draw a
quick little sketch and show you and say
this is what we're doing and it's just
an image of exactly what the shot was
going to be you know he's such a
he's such a visual director and such a
great collab collaborator he always
wanted to know my opinion he's super
super generous and I think working with
someone who has that quality and is such
an actor's director one but then two
also someone with his background and
still having that level of respect for
the cast and crew around him is really
really incredible to see I think he's a
great example
amazing just as I'm wrapping up one of
my favorite lines ever of Wednesday
Adams is this is my costume I'm a
homicidal maniac they look just like
everyone else do you have a favorite
line or moment of Wednesday in the
series
hmm
I'm trying to think I think she has
there was a line one time where they're
talking about getting ready to go to
school or like a school dance or
something and and Enid says oh do you
have a well do you know you know what
you need and Wednesday says a Bullet to
the Head okay I I like it when it got a
bit violent like that I don't know that
I think that's a good one
you're so perfect this Wednesday Jenna
congrats so nice getting to talk to you
likewise thank you very much see ya